today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza and bronx-born pizza in
Bend Oregon bronx-born and Bend and gray
block in Los Angeles at 1811 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach gray
block pizza get that hitter today's
guest is a japanese-american
entrepreneur and entertainer he is the
host of one of the most popular shows JK
news I'm so happy to have him here today
mr. Jo Jisoo Kawa
[Music]
we had a Joey Diaz episode that we sat
on for almost two months you know just
trying to cuz we just had out the comics
that came in or like you know somebody
would come in that was like you know you
don't want it to all be goofy or that's
what I liked about your channel actually
is because you you I mean you've had a
Jordan Peterson on yeah and it's super
serious right but I mean it's never too
serious because it's with you right yeah
yeah yeah yeah well I struggle with
knowing you know if I'm being I don't
know I struggle sometimes if it's a
guess that's like you know very smart or
something like Jordan Peterson like I
feel you know or somebody like that with
like I guess being afraid to joke around
because I feel like I don't know I guess
like I feel like if I joke too much with
somebody like that that they're going
they're gonna shut down you know they'll
think especially since is someone older
they'll think like older people will
feel like younger people are
manipulating them sometimes just because
of the difference in like language or or
things you like kind of say they'll
think like oh is this person making fun
of me even if you're yeah yeah yeah like
oh yeah I think is this a troll
interview right it's like a ology kind
of thing yes yeah I get it yeah yeah but
um anyways mint Congrats dude I mean I
remember when you first got on Jay King
news I saw your Instagram you were like
at a hundred thousand and like now
you're like like yeah three hundred yeah
and then like your channel two hour when
I when I first saw it I was like dang
this is crazy like this guy's super
talented and you just like within a
matter of months man yeah and thanks ya
dude for real like and I saw you live in
Minnesota
I was like no [ __ ] dude you got me I was
dying in tears it's been a while since I
started like since I cried during the
stand-up yeah your Beetlejuice bit got
me die bro
yeah that was a scary I was a I mean I
was in a scary time my life but it was
definitely kind of a ridiculous time
yeah so Joe and I saw each other in at
the Gary Vaynerchuk Show in Rochester
what would you think about would you
think about
garyvee afters had you seen him before
like would you know about garyvee before
and then would you think you're actually
one of my business partners he's he's in
that world like he used to work with
like a lot of motivational speakers and
stuff like that he put me on him right
and then he's like you wanna you want to
get to know this guy most most of these
guys I don't really like because they
don't run businesses or they don't know
what they're talking about they're I
sell dreams and stuff hmm
so they sound like like a used car
salesman to me but this dude when I
heard him I was like oh [ __ ] this guy
he's a businessman yeah he he he has his
parents I think it was a liquor store
wine company and he blew it up yeah I
think he had a wine company and then
they like tree he like tripled their
sales once he got like actively like
pushing the business I mean I had a
business to begin with exactly and then
and then the stuff that he says makes
sense and I know this because you know I
owned like a few restaurants yeah and I
have I've been in business for a while
so I'm like all right cool like I could
tell that he's not bullshitting I like
what he's saying he's straightforward
and I think that's what we need right
now we need a guy that can just be
straight about everything right yeah do
you think um yeah because I watch every
you know like it went that when things I
watch I'm like oh is this person you
know are they just giving me information
or they somebody that I could look at as
like an actual guide are they just
selling me something you know those are
the things that I think you know are my
natural inclinations when I'm watching
something like okay is this just for
entertainment yeah is this for
entertainment and education is this just
an a hidden advertisement you know yeah
um but yeah I thought it was interesting
I left out of there I I definitely
thought I was interesting I felt like I
get this feat this vibe and I can be
totally wrong it's just you know most of
the vibes I get it wrong and but that
Gary vai he's just like so into business
though that it becomes almost like an
obsession yeah oh yeah that's true like
that's where I don't want to be ever in
my life I mean I don't you know I woke
up at probably 10:30 a.m. today so I
don't think I'll ever get into that
place but um I know what you mean it's
all about our balance right you don't
obsess to the point where your
relationships suffer when you're doing
it where you have like yes I am is like
a hundred
million dollars later what does that
even mean I know I kind of get it
because I have friends like you right
and they'll do you really yeah the way
they see business is like a video game
so there are some people are super
obsessed with like different hobbies and
video games or like some people want to
surf like ten hours a day or something
like that right and that's the way this
guy's you've mastered a lot of our
listeners gonna masturbate for half and
somebody's guys been sending pictures
and artwork some guys sent me it drawing
the other day allegedly done in you know
skeet or whatever they call it you jack
off onto a piece of paper I didn't see
it I didn't see him make the paint you
know what I'm saying but I definitely
saw you know the final artwork in the
art wasn't even any good I felt bad for
looking at it and then he sent me a
message you like just look again and see
if you like the picture and I was like
and I looked again cuz I want to be I
don't want to not be somebody that
doesn't care about somebody's heart yeah
you know and it still was just horrible
it just didn't look like art look like
somebody just honestly masturbated on to
uh oh hey so I think I kind of got
tricked but anyway but yeah some of our
listeners but yeah go on you were saying
people do all kinds of yeah I just think
the thing is like a video game yeah I
think he just he's just passionate about
it right and and but you're right like I
mean sometimes obsessions and passions
can go overboard and it could destroy
people but I think he does it in a in a
more healthy way because he doesn't
preach that hashtag hustle you need to
work all day and do all this stuff if
you really listen to what he's saying
it's really there's a bigger picture to
it and it's about like connecting with
people being right and you in creating
products and businesses that are ethical
and stuff like that right so it's not
really it's not really this like work
all day work all night don't even sleep
you could sleep later mentality right I
think if you love doing anything you'll
do that for farming if you're passionate
about farming you yeah I mean like so I
think it's is just with money there's
this weird stigma around it like because
there are so many you know shady
scammers and all that stuff that's tied
to that kind of world
yeah yeah do um yeah but yeah you're
right I think about that it's like think
about that a lot I guess and maybe I
don't know if I even
says sometimes on that like like what is
like enough
are you into business to be doing
business yeah I'm into business you know
that's I'm into it I'm getting more into
it yeah yeah you know I think what
happened for me was uh I just started
getting busy and so it's like okay my
time is a commodity yeah yeah you know
and it's really the only come it's like
the only like commodity that's
definitely mine yeah um you know like
intrinsically you know or whatever yeah
so it's like you know that Buster has
from they are things started like okay I
can't do this anymore I can't do that
like I can have a conversation that's a
you know I can't hang out and just
listen to somebody that's drunk talk for
an hour yeah cuz they're not going to
nothing's gonna come of it right
nothing's gonna come up for me nothing
to come up for them yeah you know just
little things like that but it starts to
but then it becomes more and more
serious yeah it's like okay I just need
to be I need to be a little bit more
efficient yeah yeah I mean I a friend of
mine and a long time ago invested in a
in a apartment an apartment or
condominium that in New Orleans
oh [ __ ] and so that's one thing that I
got into slowly over the years there's
been like 15 years now you know we each
had like 10 grand and he says go and we
put in we got a place so then over the
years like you become like a you know a
property manager your landlord so you
have real estate you want that world so
then I started to get into it a little
bit right like I started then like over
time you know was able to sell sell and
then get to places right but then also
it's like I've realized in that time
like then now I become a landlord there
are times when I'm a landlord where I'm
seeking tenants there are times where
now part of my you know week I have to
deal with you know like dealing with
HOAs you know all that kind of stuff so
it's yeah I've definitely learned some
of it you know things like that that
make you want to think like okay at
first I'm like well maybe I'll buy an
apartment building one day yeah but do
you want the responsibility that's
another thing right I think that's what
they don't tell you is like they don't
know business is so cool owning
businesses but like they don't tell you
all the [ __ ] you have to go through
yeah yeah and if you don't and if that's
something and I think that's a thing you
know I think a lot of people feel you
know we see videos like business videos
online yeah and some of them make me
feel it makes me feel inspired but then
some
I can also feel like oh man I'm not
doing enough you know that's true I
started too late I did this I think that
but some people is business is not for
everybody yeah a hundred percent and
being like am it like that kind of stuff
like dude the other night like I'm in an
HOA call right I'm listening to on it
part of an HOA board
and dude I'm sitting there for two hours
listening while some guy who I think is
probably an alcoholic like just their
rates everyone else on the board you
know yeah but it's like I have to be I
have to do that because I commit it and
it's just yes more business gets created
so if you don't want to be a business
person you don't really like doing those
sorts of things yeah
then just don't feel bad about yourself
if you you know see those types of
videos you know like [ __ ] I'm not a
business guy yeah I mean that's that's
how I that's why I like the Gary Vee
dude cuz he doesn't come off as like a
lot of the other guys right I mean
because you're in business you know yeah
you know like who's a fraud and who is
it like if someone's just trying to sell
you a dream yeah and they're like you
want to be on this [ __ ] yacht with a
bunch of girls and [ __ ]
it's yeah and they throw one of the
girls off the yacht they're like what
what it Belinda do yeah I mean you're
better off trying to be an entertainer
an artist you get that [ __ ] for real you
know like and it doesn't cost that much
if you think about it you can rent a
yacht you get a bunch of girls didn't
want to kill your brother with a nice
gun he just killed one of his brothers
thankfully the guys like nine brothers
you know but it's still like but yes
some of its just delusional yeah but
then there are guys and I did notice he
seemed like I just got to shake his hand
and say hey we chatted for maybe six
seconds and it was uh he does seem
authentic though he seems authentic in
his desire to like lead people um in and
not getting stuck in a bad habit right
that's one thing I noticed I mean one
thing I took away from what he preaches
is like you know really give away the
content don't try to sell everything all
the time yeah and then be honest with
yourself like like if if you want to
make a million dollars be honest about
that don't [ __ ] go around and say
like yeah I want to help the world I
want to do this for charity or whatever
then get in a chair
right I mean there's a lot of people out
there that want to get into business and
they think they're saving the world or
they don't want to come off as greedy
right well they're not being honest with
them ah that's internally I was like oh
that's that's totally right that's super
interesting man yet cuz I think about
that a lot I think about like you know
if as my career starts to get bigger you
know in the potential to make more money
yeah and then but then also how to not
get caught into greed and also how to
feel like deserving of money that you
make mm-hmm like those are some things
that I even struggle with you know it's
like you know like feeling like you
deserve because sometimes my brain won't
see the hard work I put in yeah my brain
will just see this moment and my brain
will be like oh you don't deserve this
even if I do right know what you're
talking about it's like going on
vacations you can't really be on
vacation because you feel like you
didn't do enough and you don't deserve
it
right yeah yeah yeah is that do all
business people go through that I don't
know but um I don't know what that is
man oh yeah Nick just brought this
impostor syndrome what's that a
psychological pattern in which an
individual doubts their accomplishments
and has a persistent internalized fear
of being exposed as a fraud do you do
you fear that like like you kind of
might come off a certain way no I fear
like um I feel like I mean it's a
constant struggle to I mean I feel like
I'm still learning a lot about Who I am
you know I feel like uh I feel like a
lot of like I try and be as authentic as
I can
yeah I feel like it's also hard yeah to
do sometimes like it's tough to know if
your egos running some of the even a
moment or if your heart is like running
the moment or I mean being your work own
worst critic is a good trait to have
though right because you know you you
you try to hold yourself accountable
right and and I think more people
actually need that you know I mean
especially now with social media and
everybody but these big-ass [ __ ] egos
like no clue like a little table dude I
[ __ ] can't stand little table you
know I'm saying they say you can't be
mad at children dude [ __ ] that you know
what's sad was a child I know what it's
like
I've already been in those trenches dude
I
did 18 years as a child she's a little
puppet for her brother
oh really yeah a bad man yeah no that I
thought she was just a crazy you know 17
year old kid that looked real small and
was no she's like a 8 year old child man
and what what ended up happening is her
brother just really uh she he he was the
puppeteer and he I mean I don't know if
she's a fall or whatnot but she's a kid
man and then I was just like this is
[ __ ] crazy when all that stuff came
out because in the very beginning I was
old with you I was like this [ __ ] is
stupid yeah I just didn't get it like I
got some of it yeah the but they were
just seemed live it seemed to be too
fake yeah and then playing the little
tag ok yeah someone leaked out like the
the her brother coaching her and all you
got to say it like this and she's like I
don't want to and you're like no just do
it and I was like oh [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah and then her mom was in on it and
everything she got like her mom is a big
real estate person out in Canada and she
had her like luxury cars and houses to
fake the funk and I was like that's
[ __ ] up see the world is coming to a
weird-ass place man it's getting wild
there [ __ ]
yeah there it is brother yeah I hear
that yeah let's hear that check it out
yeah I don't wear the same [ __ ] she
doesn't even speak like nah but [ __ ]
since you want to say I only have a
thousand dollars and I spent that all
online belts look at this [ __ ] okay and
then start flexing that that and start
flexing that if you like it's just what
this one 2001 3000 okay 2300 [ __ ] you
can't tell me [ __ ] I got a hunter
okay well I say um okay little takeout
a-hunting on her wrist you can't tell me
[ __ ] okay is that little tay yeah that's
a no-no right I don't know no Ryder wait
oh here she is trying to do it yeah and
she doesn't even speak like that you
know like watch how she portrays herself
she just talks like a little girl she
sounds like every eight-year-old in most
neighborhoods now you say I wear this
[ __ ] every day because Wow okay good
that's good um yeah so that I mean it's
just what you know like but I feel like
you could see that you do that when
you're watching and you're like there's
no way this kid is like yeah really like
has this much like money and yeah the
money yeah where did it what are they
own 700 lemonade stands like how would
you ever even make that kind of money
but we're also a lot older than you know
the general YouTube and Instagram viewer
right you know so if I was 13 and I saw
that [ __ ] I thought I think it would be
real or like wow that's interesting
you're like I wonder if I was a kid now
and I saw that what I think it could be
real and enough people must have yeah
because there are videos of like you
know nephews of oil tycoons or whatever
what they're [ __ ] hunting Eagle oh
yeah driving Lambos and stuff oh you
know you're human right you're just like
a couple of British dudes eating human
somewhere like in Sierra Leone yeah
so the [ __ ] is right I had a life yeah
you know having a little bit of Perrier
with some human yeah yeah it's just but
I guess maybe like you were saying is
that what we've come to you know like is
that what's going on that it's just it's
all becoming a little bit to me like
everything is like a WWE promo now it's
like you know we consume things in short
clips and short and in beats almost a
hundred percent man there's so much
fraudulent [ __ ] that's going on
a lot of fraudulent [ __ ] oh yeah but do
you feel like people are starting to see
more the authenticity I mean even going
back to the garyvee like I did take away
some things I didn't feel like he was
here's what I didn't feel I get the
thing yeah I didn't feel like he was
trying to sell me anything yeah like I
did buy a ticket to go to the thing
right but I didn't feel like there was
no like coming getting this line at the
end and like pay for there was none of
that oh yeah you bought a ticket even
though you were paid to perform yeah oh
[ __ ] but yeah I just wanted to you know
contribute to the vibe you know of it
yeah I think I did anyway that's awesome
man I ever done that
oh really get it for free but yeah the
worst free person yeah
yes watched but yeah I mean I definitely
took some stuff away from it I took away
from it like he said things like you
know that the the mom-and-pop shop is
not gonna come back like you can't roam
and sighs a lot of business yeah and we
want to and I and when he said that that
hit me you know because I romanticize a
lot of business you know I have this
idea somewhere that lives in my head
that you know the that the mom you know
the mom-and-pop shop is gonna make a
comeback and you know small town America
but the numbers just aren't there to
support it yeah and he was saying like
you know that the advertising now it's
you know putting an ad in a paper that
sort of thing it just doesn't it you
have to go to your phone you know that
everything is capable right they are
like the old door-to-door salesmen and
shaking hands like a lot of that is is
gone I think it's gonna be a blend of
the two because I mean you know apps
like Yelp helped out a lot of struggling
mom-and-pop shops you know that hole in
a wall restaurant that had really good
yeah but then no one really knew about
it except for the locals mm-hmm and then
you know like the Internet gets a hold
of it and boom you know they can survive
you know passerby is heading through
town can look and see how this place got
people loved this place
yeah but then it's like these are these
subordinate like technologies it creates
like fluff all of that like that's the
thing that gets really scary yeah it's
like how much of this is fluff right
right right
you like
BOTS leaving comments or whatever right
yeah yeah like Dan's tacos you think a
dude named Dan makes good tacos bro I'm
out right it has to be like Hector's or
yeah bro Hector is bro you know dude I
want to see a bunch of kids in the
picture the first picture better have
nine or eleven Latino kids in it you
know what I'm saying all right and were
shot on each other like I want to see
that party bruh
that's so true yeah they don't see
somebody getting you know released from
prison I want to see it all on what
these tacos have some [ __ ] flaw for
ya I want to see that real [ __ ] bro
viata at go sign your pretty
entrepreneurial though a lot of people
might just think you're an entertainer
in a comedian but I think over time I'm
starting to recognize like you have that
because you're you have this we have a
similar like thing in common is is when
we were kids we would always be hustling
and trying to do things like you had
your G pigs and yeah hamsters that you
guys selling
I would sell candy at school you would
yeah man Joe Jitsu Kaba [ __ ] a little
backpack full of sprees huh I used to
sell hogs
oh now that seems dark into the Asian
underworld yeah who was buying pogs just
my class merely did you ever get into
pogs that was like a pretty big thing in
the 90s maybe it's a California thing I
think it's more you did it Nick oh yeah
did Lammers hell yeah and what was
Slammers dude Slammers where I was from
with eza got a lot of gay guys Armijo
can do a meet-up behind the rest area it
was like a metal POG it was like it was
like I mean you slam it on top of the
park so the way you play is like you
know you get five pogs I get five or
whatever we stack it up and then like we
put it upside down and we slam them with
the Slammers and everything anything
that flips over we get to keep oh wow
yeah no we didn't play any of that did
we used to play this game
um I mean everybody had head lice by us
so that's like a constant game of you
have you ever had head lice no no yeah I
think that's more of like a regional
thing we had like worms oh you did oh
did if somebody got worms dude you would
take him outside and burn them no you
never had like worms that would crawl
out of your butt and stuff
[ __ ] no whoa dude we're about to go go
in deep yeah man tell me about this dude
if somebody let me tell you somebody had
worms come other but bas dude they're
not allowed back at church I thought
that was pretty common for his kids like
we can go play in the sandbox and
[ __ ] extremely on our words or
whatever I remember like I maybe this is
a Asian thing but we my parents would
remedy it by [ __ ] pouring vinegar up
my ass
oh really yeah dang bro I was like I
thought everyone went through this [ __ ]
uh-uh I don't even know what the hell
dude I think that's how I mean that's
frickin rare you wormed bro that's a
rare vinaigrette you guys are making
over there right what else would they
put it in there anything else no I was
just I just I was just like yeah we have
vinegar that's it didn't how are they do
it one of them like hold your legs open
or more like my mom would be like all
right well like you know when your kid
and they help you wipe your ass and [ __ ]
you just get in that position right yeah
[ __ ] booty in the air and then they just
pour a cup of vinegar in my dick yeah
well this sounds like some kind of
rapper stuff dude this don't like
something it's like an initiation for a
gang or something yeah this sound like
something you would see on some old uh
you know some Lil Wayne [ __ ] nah that
was one of these lusher or Kelly does to
people this seems like how are Kelly
makes salad dressing you know what's
[ __ ] up too I probably could have just
went to the doctor and got like a pill
or something and dewormed myself so they
would just pour it in and that would
kill him yeah I mean what are the worms
right I mean I would assume I don't know
man I was like in elementary school PI
like first or second grade or something
but did you think about just sitting
around having worms just like being
inside of your body I mean you're
basically a bait shop at that yeah you
know what I make me out those I remember
I had an itchy ass but and I kept
telling my parents like what's going on
man [ __ ] balls been itching for ages
and they're like wow yeah making my
making me pee my see over there grab my
crotch when people say it's you but all
that stuff I'm gonna grab my crotch and
there's all the ingles it just makes me
nervous
yeah yeah I keep my butthole pretty
clean I feel like overall you know I
think there was a couple years but I
wasn't really caring about it yeah but
as an adult I've really you know I shot
up my shell shop you know how did you
how did you deal with the head lice what
was that like Oh everybody had it I mean
you would give it to your friend you
[ __ ] sneak up and give it to a girl
you like so you could bring her that
shampoo a couple days later well you you
would flake it on them like you would go
just sneak up behind him and just be
near him long enough
cuz bro they had some rare strands wrong
they had african-american head lice at
all types basic white dude head lice
yeah bro the African American age um poq
Ross the [ __ ] room on your head yeah
they do a layup other allies would be
giving them like scores Oh nine you know
whom will be jumping over each other
when I'm sitting in chairs when I'm
ordering a pizza while they're in the
air all kind of stuff but yeah head lice
was popular while I was from what other
games dude they had this big nude they
had this big dude named Wayne Wayne he
was named Wayne two times first a middle
name because his parents couldn't decide
if they wanted to name it for his first
name or his middle name until they
[ __ ] got in a fight about it and then
they both get out of Maine way no out of
anger Holmes like oh you're not gonna
[ __ ] let me name him Wayne and I'm
gonna [ __ ] name him Wayne and the
other ones like oh you ain't gonna
[ __ ] let me name him Wayne then I'm
naming him Wayne anyway Wayne yeah
that's hilarious agree on how it's
spelled or like no okay you know you've
had to agree to disagree this was
disagree to disagree I'm [ __ ] now they
got a double wedding
oh man they got Wayne squared and
ironically horrible at math dude this
dude was on this dude was severely
uneducated and he was in school too he's
probably but I remember him being 40 or
maybe even 50 years old and probably in
elementary school eighth or ninth grade
and that's it lets you stay in dude cuz
I remember his hair started falling out
in class at some point people started
getting scared cuz people thought he got
bit by something that's why his hair was
falling out but it was because of
adulthood you know he'd man he'd gone on
deep into adulthood anyway but the thing
was yeah people got lice by us what else
do people get man man for some reason
when you paint those pictures
like where you went to school and all
that I I remember that Adam Sandler
movie waterboy oh yeah on the bayou and
yeah and then I picture like your school
house being like just made from two by
fours and just a local TLC I mean like
let me think we had a dude they had um I
remember this managed to give me a ride
to school and he uh and he would roll up
the windows and he thought I was he he
thought that I thought I was smart yeah
he's like oh you think you're smart well
if I'd miss the bus he gave me a ride to
school he blow cigarette smoke all in
the [ __ ] car with his elementary
school yeah our middle this is middle
okay it's grade six rate and then he
would make me do my spelling words with
smoke in the air oh my god real [ __ ]
boy could spell a smoke in the air
that's you know he's like how you gonna
score a hundred if there's a fire you
know dad I'm like I don't [ __ ] know
you know but then I would try to spell
and it was hard but all that Marlboro
red cigarette smoke just hotbox this car
and I'm sitting there trying to rattle
through the word inconvenience you think
this guy was jealous of you going to
school I think he was jealous of
something but also think he was trying
to parent me somehow and he didn't have
a lot of proper skills you know I see
but he figured if I could fill this car
with enough smoke and that boy can still
spell that's kind of creative though
right if [ __ ] gets weird he's gonna be
okay dude I feel like having some kid
with worms coming out of their butt
seems like it almost seems like a buffet
or something I thought it's in the Sudan
you know because a lot of the countries
they eat worms you know they'll leave
really oh yeah that least slugs and
worms and larvae and I even been in one
of those places would you do it oh I've
eaten you've done it yeah I've been in
South Africa and eating a bunch of and
they get some big meal
no no mealworms of the little ones I
think they get some big was that like a
big ass caterpillar or something yeah
something like that and that thing you
got a really known it tastes like a Twix
I tried a silkworm before did you
yeah they eat that in Korea yeah yeah
but I I mean I didn't grow up eating
silkworms you so you can get silk if you
[ __ ] practice some of your old
hobbies we had a bunch of silkworms in
you but there you can [ __ ] you know
I'm saying together
whether on the wall no people like what
am i doing
like oh just making Christmas gifts for
everyone but no let's talk more about
entrepreneurism man I like this kind of
like thinking about this kind of stuff
did you think you would because is it in
your culture or in your nature to be
like a business person like tell me it
from a cultural standpoint no actually
well um my parents they came - they came
to the States
mhm so they're from Japan right but out
there they were you're Japanese
yeah I'm Japanese oh nice man husband
must I do you speak Japanese yes nice
yeah do you that's all I know
conversation yeah that's on us so um so
the funny thing is they came to the
States because they wanted to pursue a
life of music oh really I want to be
right yeah they want to be rappers on I
wanted to be classical musicians like my
dad's opera singer my mom plays piano
yeah so I grew up not stereotypically
Asian you know didn't come here with
money did they come here with not much
money or what was it like were there was
there no you see um they they grew up in
enriched like households okay but the
reason why we went broke is because they
were never taught how to deal with money
how to save money how to be responsible
with any of that oh really
yeah and then in the 80s when they came
in Japan's economy was real good so most
of their music students were kids of
rich Japanese executives and stuff like
from Sony and you know Toyota and all
them yeah that was booming in America
not in the 80s and 90s yeah yeah so so
during that time you know man they were
getting like a hundred two hundred
dollars an hour for teaching piano
singing all that [ __ ] right there was a
really highly revered so there what
happenes teacher you were really I mean
so they were rolling and dull right and
then boom a lot of the students start
going back to Japan they weren't doing
things right so they didn't know how to
maintain that and I remember the bill
collectors keep calling in and Lane they
wanted to keep up with appearances so
they kept buying like my [ __ ] and I
wouldn't I remember being a kid like man
how come you pretend like you're being
rich like really yeah I'm like I was
getting mad at them like why are we
buying new cars all the time
because you guys can't even buy me my
Christmas present but you gotta wait a
certain way you know you're like I got
[ __ ] yes they're out here flexing and
I'm going to a school that's like like
we live in a neighborhood that was like
like lower middle class or whatever
right and I'm like but the people that
they hang out with we're all you know
we're palos verdes is yeah yeah rich
area like that so I'm like why why you
pretend like you're rich all the time
what I didn't know is that they that's
the world that they're used to they just
don't understand like they when they
first moved to the u.s. they didn't know
the concept of a ghetto they didn't know
what like cheap rent means dangerous
they didn't understand that they did it
because it's safe as hell in Japan like
oh yeah Japan is very safe you've been
um yeah yeah I have been um somewhere
but you don't got to worry about being
robbed you don't have to and there's no
there's no like just because something
is cheap doesn't mean that it's
dangerous yeah
so we first moved into like um like
Eagle wood yeah so we're now it's soso
because why because you don't you don't
think cheap dangerous you just think oh
this is a good price that's what they
thought right so then it's interesting I
was born in that area and then and and
we would walk around like my grandma
would took would take me on little walks
and stuff it was it mostly black or
Latino or what was majority black and
Latino yeah majority black at the time
and then like some guys were like doing
a prank I guess and they threw bottles
of water at her and she freaked out and
then our I guess our family doctor was
like why you guys in that neighborhood
that's a rough neighborhood and they're
like what I I thought it was just like
little Africa yeah cuz they don't know
anything about American history they
don't know how like there's all this
difference in like class exactly a lot
of oh yeah so a lot of neighbor the
poorest neighborhoods were a lot of
times black especially in cities yeah
yeah yeah right yeah so so they don't
didn't know that it was dangerous or
whatever they don't know any of that
stuff it's just a little Africa that's
that's that's all they saw it they were
like oh yeah we live in little Africa
you know and so um you know people were
just telling them you got to get out of
there so then we moved to a more like a
little bit better than that
um it's a little city called Gardena oh
yeah yeah yeah it's in the South Bay and
that's kind of where I grew up for most
of my life around like Latinos and
blacks and what's it like growing up in
California man I feel like growing up in
California seems like everything seems
to be I don't know if it's there doesn't
seem to be a strong sense of community I
don't feel like in the LA area like well
if your pants or your rat like means a
lot like you yeah I mean something in
like your little neighborhood like
everything I don't know it's like people
are a lot more it seems like connected
yeah um I don't know like my core values
I don't know like it just seems
California I'm every time I see a young
person here or here somebody grow up in
like man I couldn't imagine that I'm not
saying it's wrong or anything it just
seems so wild to me you know a hundred
percent I know what you're talking about
cause just going out of state going to
small towns like I see it man
but they also you know you you probably
have what like generations of history in
that area right right so there's a lot
of pride and right and if you look at La
in general like there's what like two
million people in the city and and it's
the city's constantly changing you mean
in the actual city I think it's like 14
million in like is that I thought it was
okay
damn that's even way population in Los
Angeles named in the greater LA yeah yes
they are great if you're talking about
like the Sauber's not just downtown
wherever in Hollywood right are they
uses 3.9 that's still a that's still a
ton of people yeah right that's like
four million yeah right but if you think
about the history of LA mm-hmm oh crap
laney million in the greater los
Angelino
so also you're making a very bad Asian
right now because it says Dan 18 point
six eight I think he might have been
extrapolating to 2018 and it's probably
about 20 now so I don't what extrapolate
nailed it man I did kind of did you
fluctuate for like Joe can't even see
that
I'm sorry Joe 20 million people in
Greater Los Angeles area
well and Gardena consider Greater Los
Angeles area yeah so it's a suburb of
the city but I think a lot changes in LA
so just I mean in my grandparents is
like a generation like the some cities
didn't even exist right so if you if you
talk about like LA it depends on what
area to because you're around
entertainment right and what I notice is
a lot of entertainment like West Side
Hollywood Mia Valley those cities are
built by transplants right and I was
born and raised going yeah I was born
and raised here so I have family that's
been here since like mmm early 1900s I
know like so they have a lot of history
right but their neighborhoods changed
too oh wow that's so crazy yes so it's
like things change her so much that yeah
that would affect history like yeah a
lot of where I'm from a lot of the
history is based on okay this building
has been here for this long yeah
you know this family has lived in this
exact place for this long or there's a
lot more small town lower because things
don't change as much and when things
don't change as much it's going to be
easier to have history yep because the
history is more video can see the
history you can see that everything is a
little bit of an artifact yeah it's kind
of like you you know people say oh la so
diverse and it's like now really we're
just a huge collection of different
segregated cities that's what I feel
like - yeah I hate that sometimes when
people like it's so diverse here it's
like I mean I know exactly like in my
neighborhood it's like I feel you know
kind of tertiary because it's mostly
Middle Eastern right I feel second there
you know it's not like yeah I don't live
I've never lived in a black neighborhood
but I know that they have them you know
like I don't even see any black
neighbors in my you know in my in the
blocks by me or you know black personnel
from Westwood I don't think I've ever
seen a black person honestly yeah by
UCLA I have but when I think about it
honestly thinking right now yeah I don't
think I've ever seen a black person in
my neighborhood except for if I go over
to like the AAA meetings and stuff then
I'll see them
yeah but they come from diff
city's right they came over to do to go
to that so yeah you're right it's like
we claimed diversity so much out here
there's this claim of diversity yeah but
you don't feel like it is that way no
man it's I think it's just the space we
got a lot of Spacey right so I mean like
places like New York or San Francisco
you're kind of forced because there's
not that much space right spice it's
hard to make your little different
neighborhoods yeah
but out here I mean if you look at East
LA right well the San Gabriel Valley
yeah and you if you think about how many
Asians there are from Monterey Park all
the way down for like seven cities
straight you have a population of sixty
percent plus Asians [ __ ] that's why
hopefully I usually choose the other on
ways I choose to not go through that
area I'm just you yeah we should have
like we should factor that in a little
bit but yeah it's crazy I didn't know
that yeah you know do you know the
second largest population of Japanese
people outside of Japan is in Brazil
yeah yeah they tripped me out too I was
like dang that's crazy yes yeah there's
just things like there's pockets of yeah
you don't realize it so yeah I mean I
it's so funny because when I think of
Los Angeles culture I think mostly of
Latino culture I think yeah do you or no
when you think about an agenda sense I
guess you grew up here yeah I mean it's
it's I feel like you can't have LA
without Mexicans yeah you know that's
it's just a part of it but at the same
time there's just so many different
faces of LA yeah like Hollywood's its
own thing right you know but I've been
hearing and reading a lot of stuff from
a lot of influencers talking about like
oh la is full of fake people and this
and that and I'm like nah man that's
just your shitty circle of friends in in
in everyone trying to be entertainers
yeah like the most of us you know real
la folks are totally different from that
dude it's soap man I love hearing you
say this because this takes me to
something that I noticed when I went and
did you guys's show and Joe is one of
the creators of some of Joe of JKD no
just kidding news getting news right and
they have a huge influence and and I've
run across so many people now since
being on there and people will come
jános that's cool where's all the Asian
kids huh it's especially people that
work in like better near computers well
honey but there I'm like let me check
your butt for worms make sure you're a
real fan you can use some apple cider
vinegar for that I'm gonna put a little
bit of apple cider yes you know no Joe
actually sent this cap full of apples
but know one thing I noticed was how
much you more like me in joking around
that you guys were yeah then the way
that I feel like I'm allowed to be by
the Hollywood community oh yeah as
opposed to being into your environment
and what I'm just now realizing oh this
is more of a Los Angeles community yeah
and that that in that place I can joke
and be more like I can at home mm-hmm
like the same place that I'm from nope I
can joke the exact same way and be
myself really be of just like not have
to just know that I'm coming from a good
place and then still joke around yeah a
hundred percent whereas in Hollywood and
some of these have like types of shows
that are so produced yeah so outrageous
I can't do that yeah that was the first
thing I was like holy [ __ ] like yeah
there's there's Asian people and Latinos
that are Mexican people that are joking
about like [ __ ] funny real [ __ ] yeah
they're not all offended by everything
yeah a hundred percent that's why we
created that show is because it was like
a way to really give the LA culture that
isn't on screen yeah you know like
Asians and Mexicans make a huge part of
LA but we're not represented in the
media that way right so when we created
the show it was like yo let me show you
something that's real and let me give
you guys a voice of what we represent I
think a lot of people needed that
they're just like oh [ __ ] you know this
exists dude I needed that so much we're
sitting there we're talking about
something yeah and you guys are like
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] or something
you know and it's like yeah we don't
mean the guys actually we're not making
we're and I'm paraphrasing 100% yeah
yeah we're talking about but we say that
all the time look around now yeah we do
and people know your hearts are in a
good place and they are just joking yeah
cuz we're just trying to get to the
bottom of the truth and we know like
we're trying
get that bedroom I mean living room
friend talk into the open you know and
then there's so much fake [ __ ] going
around online anyway so why hold back
why be afraid like I think people people
want to hear it yeah yeah I don't know
no no dude I love exactly what you're
saying man and it's so funny I was just
talking this week I'm on the regular
episode of the podcast about like you
know trying to make sure that if if and
as you know the podcast has grown my
podcast you know has grown to just check
in and see what's going on with my own
authenticity you know and not get too
caught up in like okay trying to make
you know you know put out certain stuff
or like just making sure that we're
appeasing I know a bigger audience but
also just trying to stay true like yeah
the things I'm that I think about and
also the things that I'm afraid of yeah
I think dude it's like this probably the
longest conversation I've ever had with
a Japanese person you know well I mean
that's not your fault I mean you grew up
in the south and yeah you know what's
funny is man so like I actually there's
a part of me that that kind of
fantasizes in romanticizes living in the
Bayou like there was a lot it's no [ __ ]
you're gonna be you you can you imagine
me what so great overalls and just
because I love nature yeah like they
always say people want what they can't
have
Yeah right and I wanted to have a
crawfish farm right because I love
eating crawfish oh yeah I love fishing
yeah and I just I love lazy rivers I
just like sitting on an inner tube and
going down a lazy river do you should go
to Vietnam maybe had heart you're
Vietnamese maybe you know what the funny
thing is
so my girlfriend Jess she's from Texas
right and then she got with me she's
like man I wanted to get with a la Asian
guy but I ended up getting a redneck and
that's not what I wanted and I'm like
same for her you know I didn't I wanted
this you know good Texas white girl but
I ended up getting a very critical Asian
woman who criticizes my every step we
both is like damn man we didn't get what
we wanted
but we got each other yeah that's so
funny man
dude it's oh man this is so cool okay I
want to interrupt our interview with Joe
to let you know about the simple
messaging reviews and insights for local
business I'm talking about podium podium
uses the convenience of text messaging
to become the obvious choice online no
more hold music phone tag or piling up
of voicemails 90% of consumers prefer
messaging and 99% of texts get opened we
know that texts we always see them so
finely podium has found a way to take
business into your SMS it's convenient
for customers and it's flexible for you
everything from scheduling appointments
to closing the deal is as easy as
sending a quick text it's great for auto
shops medical offices large transaction
retailers furniture jewelry etc home
services and professional services
conversations that start with
convenience in in more sales and texting
as can as convenient as it gets and
podium is how you're going to do it go
to podium comm slash tpw to get 10% off
your monthly subscription meet your
customers where their screens are go to
podium comm slash tpw to get started and
save 10% this past weekend is supported
by hellofresh I started using hello
fresh again and it's been great
I forgot about how nice it is to like
have the ingredients you can have your
lady over your man or someone you just
met off the internet it doesn't even
matter look you can learn a lot about
somebody by making a recipe together see
if they're nice see if they're friendly
see if they're dangerous and maybe you
should call the cops
hello fresh it's the meal kit delivery
service that shops plans and delivers
your favorite recipes and pre-measured
ingredients so you can just cook eat and
enjoy and I knew you hear the cook you
hear the cook part you think that sounds
like it's gonna be hectic it's not and
it's fun if you got children or anybody
small that you like to hang out with
they might love hellofresh and you're
gonna
love doing it together there's three
plans to choose from
classic veggie and family each box is
made up of fresh responsibly obtained
ingredients from carefully selected
farms and high rated trusted sources hey
where'd you get those yams from a
trusted source simple recipes with
pictured step-by-step instruction cards
recipes take about 30 minutes get
delicious filling meals delivered right
to your door every week for less than
$10 per serving and free shipping and
now for $20 off your first three boxes
that's a total of $60 off visit
hellofresh comm slash Theo 60 and enter
promo code Theo 60 that's hellofresh
dot-com
slash th EO 6-0 and use code th EO 6-0
for a total of $60 off it's just so cool
hearing you like make me think about
some of this stuff because yeah it's
like yeah it's like dis now I see a
little bit more like man this yeah like
we're not against Hollywood but we we
both have a similarity of feeling like
[ __ ] this doesn't even represent my
sense of humor like no where can I even
find my represents my sense of humor
anymore you're good to go make it and I
had to come and [ __ ] be like holy
[ __ ] yeah Mison Zoomers are so afraid
yeah because I'm trying to work in
Hollywood yeah that I can't these guys
are [ __ ] they're do really doing the
jokes ed I want to be telling just
fearless ly talking you know and no one
you're coming from a good place but then
still able to joke around that's how it
used to be right I think it's a little
bit more dangerous though for white
males right now right so I think maybe
in the past it was a little bit
different I mean just just three years
ago I remember watching your stand-up
set 2015 yeah um it was up on Netflix
after you came on the show yeah they
were like everyone was like oh watch
deal stuff it's good yeah so I watched
it and I was like oh [ __ ] you know this
is this is a lot edgy or theall than
then yeah now yeah but no one I can't
even do that on JK news even we had to
scale-back right some of our word
choices are gay jokes whatever like pee
or is just a sensitive time right now
man I'm and I'm having a hard time
adjusting because like you said even if
we're coming from a good place
it it outrages a lot of people right you
know we recently did this one article
about a dude that got raped by this hot
lady yeah and then but I was it's hard
not to joke like every guy fantasizes
that ya know to me oh dude I am in yeah
and I got hated for cuz they're like
you're not taking rape seriously and I'm
like I can't she's so [ __ ] funny I
wish I was raped by her too but it's
hilarious yeah but I just I can't joke
like that anymore cuz it hurts a lot of
people and then I had to kind of take a
step back and go you know do I want to
be like the old guy that goes back in my
day we were able to say those jokes I
think you do though you know what I mean
I do want to be that guy like in a way
you know like yeah I'm not going against
what you're saying here like it's making
me think like you know like I hear what
you're saying like oh you're not taking
rape seriously but it's like I would
take a yes if some man somebody broke
into somebody's house and [ __ ] raped
him yeah I take that extremely seriously
right like if but I so funny I'm just
listening into a book right now this by
doctor thinking guy's name is Michael
gardener it's called out of the shadows
and it's um it's all about a sexual
addiction in that in those sorts of
behaviors and they they're talking about
this exact occurrence and it's a and he
was saying in this book that if a 14
year old or a 15 year old boy
hooks up with like a 50 year old 40 year
old woman a beautiful third whatever 30
they see that as a score in their book
they may later on and in life see that
as like a sexual abuse or something but
if a seemingly normal you know
can you look that up Nick you find it
it's out Michael Gartner out of the
shadows yeah is that it you see things I
think it's called out of the shadows
it's a book but but anyway he was saying
that the kids see that as a score they
see that it and I think to myself I'm 15
yeah because that's where your frame of
reference is coming from you
when you were 15 like now as an adult I
know I I feel like I don't even have to
say that that's wrong right but it's
wrong you know kids being taking
advantage of but then why can't we play
with the idea of how funny it is yeah
because that's a dream come true for
like a lot of 15 year-olds yeah dr.
Patrick Carnes I'm sorry this that's it
understanding sexual addiction but it
just it's not really as much about
sexual it's about sexual addiction but
it's also just about how we behave
sexually and how you view things and
he'll different patterns in our lives
and stuff like that some deep [ __ ] beer
I don't know you were into like reading
text books like that oh dude that book
is fascinating but nice dude it's
fascinating how like our behaviors and
what we do like even in like cyber sex
and like yeah how pornography affects
like you know how we how it affects us
and like yeah you know um and just how
things become compulsive so we're
they're not just for fun anymore
you know and you're doing something like
you know like hell I won't even jerk I
won't even start my car until jerked off
you know oh that's true that's kind of
like when you know a lot of us just
can't go to sleep until we [ __ ] beat
it yeah you know that's crazy that
really that's true because then over
time it's like you're not beat you at
one time you were like I can't wait to
get home to [ __ ] this imaginary girl in
my room you know and that was healthy
yeah you know like oh man this bad
little vixens gonna get it you know this
invisible 37 year old cat is here you're
working with nice tits because that's
who you fantasized about because that's
the only person you knew the only woman
I saw every day was [ __ ] Miss blinda
you know
her face was fly by with this scoop of
[ __ ] steaming tots right in front of
her face dude or that Sears catalog yeah
and I remember one year she lost a
couple pounds bro she lost probably only
like nine pounds and it probably wasn't
even a diet she just had the flu damn I
remember one day seeing that steam and
scoop come up towards my face and being
like man I'd like to honestly bust all
over that lady's front you know maybe
that's why our imagination is so good we
had to work with something you know yeah
you're mad yeah your imagination to come
home and you know figure it out dude
armor or mom being like did somebody
draw circles on all your pillows I'm
like
have some respect for Drew but yeah we
had to imagine it but now it's like yeah
like you're saying it for me it got to
be a habit or I had a jerk off your bed
and then it was just a bat then it's a
habit that's true
like my brain isn't able to have like
that influence that mainly influence
inside of me while it rests at night and
it becomes a compulsive behavior but
that's what a lot of that book was about
but so so people got offended that you
joked about a 14 year old or whatever
hooking up with an older woman yeah I
mean and it happens all the time like
there was this one article where there
was this hot teacher that would like do
it with her student oh yeah for high
school students or about 15 to 17 and
I'm like thinking hmm if I was at that
age that would be like a movie like a
young come true yeah that would be like
Rudy right you'd be like the Japanese
Rudy Ruettiger the guy who like comes
into and gets into the good school and
then finally for one day the smoking-hot
white teacher yeah only been banging the
other students yeah the white boys in
the class finally let you run out there
on our field and it's like damn I made
it you know yeah that that basically and
you sack or what exactly and she keeps
inviting me for extra credit or whatever
yeah and then you go back to working at
the mill you know yeah
still playing forbidden forbidden love
you know yeah you just spraying silk out
of your budget the factory for the rest
of your lives like Asian roots yeah but
I was like yes so we could laugh about
this we could joke about it right but a
lot of you know I thought I thought our
fans would be cool with it because they
are cool with a lot of crazy [ __ ] that
we yeah I felt like it was very cool
over there right now do you think
there's a legion of people that are just
wanna not be cool with stuff cuz that
seems to be it could be persona these
days it's like oh somebody who's just
unhappy and doesn't like winners doesn't
like it when people are doing well
that's true I mean there's that too
but when it's a majority of the comments
oh wow kind of tell oh there yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's all in execution too I
think sometimes we forget the fact that
you know sometimes we have to put it
out there and say hey I think this is
wrong but joke about it because I think
you do that really well yeah like when
you had your bit about about about the
the special kid yeah and I was like dude
that's hilarious because man it's hard
to go there yeah and it's like how do
you make fun of that but then you did it
in a way where where we were laughing
together instead of laughing at the
special kid yeah so I was like dang
that's cool yeah that was my friend me
it's tough because it's like so am I not
allowed to talk about somebody that has
Down syndrome because they like so then
it's almost like I have to exclude them
from my life and I think that's even
worse I agree
cuz you're not humanizing them anymore
you're like making them so sacred and
special that like you can't make fun of
them right but or you can't even include
them it was actually you're making fun
of them so yeah it's like oh there's a
person with Down syndrome I'm not even
gonna talk to them because if I do
someone's gonna take a picture or
someone's gonna say something or
someone's gonna you know if I shake
their hand the wrong way I'll give them
a hug or or something that that then
people are gonna blow that out of
proportion just to yeah it makes it bit
like yeah let's make them like a poodle
if I can go near them but I can't
interact yeah yeah I think that's what
it is but I mean I don't know man I grew
up around like my mom's a roaster he's a
roaster roni man she loves roasting
people she was in Japan right and then
so Mike my grandma's that a [ __ ] like
she's at this Alzheimer home like
justjust what do you call them right you
better stay in there stay in there Jodie
and one of these nurses like the he
looks like a big like sumo wrestler
right and then and then so I was
babysitting my friend's kid at the time
and went to go see my grandma and he
wanted to impress the kid and he was
like hey hey remember me I'm a ninja I'm
a warrior and my mom's like shut up fool
you're fat as hell you're a sumo
wrestler and we were dying like everyone
was dying and she just went in on him
and I'm like and I'm like that's that's
what life should be like roast each
other have fun you know like don't take
it too serious you know he was laughing
too but I don't know if it's a cultural
thing like we just roast each other all
day
I don't know I just feel like people are
really sensitive yeah I feel like it's I
mean and you may have a rare mom like
some sometimes you just get that mom
that smiling out you know and she's
having fun is that like a regular
Japanese cultural thing at all or that's
just like your mom is also a rare
element
I feel like culturally it doesn't sound
as harsh as it is in English
so it sounds cute and endearing so the
words sound like playground talk but the
things that they're saying it's if you
said it here it's me like like outside
of even just Japanese culture right it's
like talking about wait isn't a big deal
like you'll go to family gatherings and
then people whether you're Filipino or
Chinese or whatever you're some aunt is
gonna make a comment about you being too
fat or too skinny
right and that's just it's just the way
that they talk and joke around yeah
but out here you know it's kind of
touchy you don't say things like that
you don't get too personal but over
there there's no such thing as like
personal right people say whatever the
hell they want well it's like we started
to look we started to put property you
know one of the things that where we
switch from being tribal to being on
tribal and really started claiming
possession was when we made property
making property lines yeah like when a
guy said okay we're not we're not a
group anymore
this is my property line hmm and then
another guy did that he's like okay well
then this is my property yeah and then a
guy's like okay well this is my wife
like you know things weren't communal
anymore yeah you know and who's that
book that everybody reads that was on
rogue and the guy tribe no what is it
called that sounds familiar man it was
about
Sebastian Junger yes was it about Mara
that's the book right and so this is a
lot about and this talks about this book
by Sebastian Junger and it talks about
when things went from being communal
where we all worked it we like when
people would move in a tribe it was like
sometimes you would fall in love with a
woman across the tribe but that was okay
and there were different kids in the
tribe but at the whole tribe took care
of everyone's kids I heard about that
and very yeah you know and sometimes you
might have went for two years and been
in love with one woman and you switch to
someone else and
and she found another maid in the tribe
yeah and but it was cool and it was cool
it's very communal you can almost feel
that in our cysts I feel like if I think
about that when I think deep down in my
soul that seems like I could do that
well yeah yeah yeah yeah because I would
my feelings would be hurt sometimes but
also I would have feelings of love and
no matter what feelings I was having I
would always have my tribe to take that
would always I'm included no matter what
like that was the thing about a tribe no
matter if you were the one whose heart
was being broken or you lost a child or
some you always had your group you know
you always had your tribe that's one of
the goals that I want to have with my
crew is we want to have a cul-de-sac of
just all of us living together hmm and
we would help each other like in a
village way mm-hmm we're like we'll take
care of each other's kids and all that
stuff yeah I think it's that same book
but I was watching this documentary
about like the the idea of love mm-hmm
and in the sense that we know today it's
just very new like to our society as
young beings we didn't we didn't know it
that way romantic love with just one
partner for the rest of our lives is a
brand new concept mmm like and and it
might be that book or it might be
something else but don't quote me on
this but I know a specific thing that I
learned about it is there was one Native
American group that like the rule was if
you have sex with a woman that's
pregnant then any man that has sex with
her during her pregnancy becomes the
father of the child oh wow so then the
kid could come out with like ten daddies
this might have been sex at dawn that
Chris Ryan book it sounds like it's part
of that or it could have been this oh I
see what you're saying well yeah she but
it was a good thing for her because you
know when the kid comes out then
there'll be ten daddies right and all
the ten daddies couldn't like teach the
kid how to hunt how to you know how to
jump like it different dads would have
different skills yeah yeah and the the
love is there for everyone yeah yeah
and then the responsibility was if
there's a kid crying and the closest
adult is is kind of responsible of
picking up that kid and just like
helping the kid out so there was more of
a community and I think it's big there's
just a spread responsibility
so I'm like dang that's really cool yeah
I love that and I think that's one thing
you get in like a neighborhood you know
or you get in a small town yeah in a
small town like I remember feeling you
definitely a lot more sense of you know
yeah there were only so many kids on our
street so all of the parent you know
everybody kind of knew that you know 9
or 11 kids on our street are in a
certain you know area or something um
did you grow up in a big family do you
have a lot of brothers and sisters I got
three brothers and sisters but outside
of that that was it yeah you know both
my parents uh my father wasn't an only
child but all of his siblings died and
then my mother was an only child so we
don't have a big family it's growing now
with my sister be cool it's pretty cool
yet it's almost like we're pioneers in
our family and we also my father of my
father was 70 when I was born he was an
old man right
damn and so he had a family from a first
marriage and they I mean one event like
they aren't like they were like
extremely well-off yeah you know and
then we had we just we were not you know
and so as always as crazy because they
owned like things all over the city and
like huge theaters and like
neighborhoods and like there was it was
just crazy that like you know my dad had
had this whole other family yeah so your
dad was like big man in town but you got
you got to you saw all the success but
you didn't get a piece of that right we
didn't get a piece that well he gave
that away to his kids or before he had
us yeah once he had our family his kids
disowned him Oh from what I understood
yeah yeah were you like the secret
family a little bit but then I mean he
didn't I don't think he cheated on his
wife with my mom hmm
but I think if we were like this
separate family and at that point like
we never interacted with his kids like I
never saw his kids from his first
marriage until I was at their I was at
the funeral and I saw them that's great
you considered them your siblings though
no no there's just yeah they've never
ever reached out I mean I know my
family's made so much siblings made some
efforts to reach out yeah yeah yeah I
have any interest you know damn
and the sad is the loss of the biggest
loss of that is just that we don't get
to share whatever elements that they
know and whatever elements we know about
dad you know so it's almost like he
would be more of a complete person in
our hearts if we got together to share
that but for some reason
you know I don't think that seems like
that's not an interest of theirs yes
kind of like a Louisiana Game of Thrones
kind of a little bit you know it's like
yeah like everybody's [ __ ] related
yeah it's like nobody wants to share the
photos yeah yeah and it's like
everybody's got a do you want to be
friends do you not do you want to
continue the family do you want to team
up cuz man that's that's pretty crazy
genetic war yeah they're easy when
people start hiding their semen in the
other room like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you want to make a baby better
[ __ ] find something you know what the
trip is um so my girlfriend's got a
little brother and she always thought he
was her half-brother mm-hmm until he
took the 23andme and her mom her mom's
all turns out what he's Mugsy Bogues no
she turns out she he's a full brother oh
really but this whole time
her dad was like I don't believe the the
you know that he's my full son hmm so so
the thing is um she her mom ran away to
Ohio from Texas with with the two kids
or or she had to her little brother
there and then she got into a real bad
place got in with the wrong crowd her
mom and then she lost custody so high oh
yeah she lost custody she I think she
got into drugs and sure I could happen
in Ohio yeah yeah so then when that
happened
her dad's family my girlfriend's dad's
family they got ahold of my girl Jess
and brought her back to Texas but not
the little brother oh reisel they grew
up separately they still talked and
stuff like that and then and then and
then you know her mom kept saying yeah
that's that's that's her that's his son
but then no one really believed it
because of how crazy she was yeah and
then when he took the 23andme test it
was like oh by the way you're related to
these people on her dad's side and bam
it was like oh [ __ ] he was my full son
so then they all decided to kind of mean
in Texas and all that and I was there to
see everything unfold and I was like
this is crazy damn dude
yeah there must been a lot how it's a
lot for her man I mean like I was like
isn't that kind of cool though that you
find out that he's your full brother not
your half and then she's like yeah feels
like we're closer just yeah though we
Bend the same oh yeah
just didn't just to know yeah man I was
like damn that's crazy
I was just lammles Wow yeah watching it
all unfold man I was like there with the
popcorn just wow what is something do
Japanese people like white people or not
oh yeah man I mean you know there was
bad times in World War two but I feel
like and who did it in World War two
let's be honest I don't know you see you
know what the weird thing is I have
family on both sides yeah so my you know
my uncle Saul Pearl Harbor happened in
in Hawaii he was a little watercress
farmer boy and he saw the planes drop
and that's what made him join the
American armrests out there slinging boy
yeah yeah and on mine really they made
him join the American army yeah because
he was like they don't think we're
American so I'm gonna do the most
American thing possible Wow and join the
army and that's what a lot of Japanese
did during that time that lived in
America because I don't know if you know
about the whole internment camps and
stuff but a lot of Japanese people on
the west coast were sent away to camps
because they were trusted Wow
and in during that time where y'all
untrustworthy or not no man dude super
trustworthy I mean they would send World
War one Japanese veterans into the camps
too and it's like already fought for
this country bro what the hell yeah but
a lot of them worst like you know what
maybe we weren't American enough so they
wanted to prove their love for America
yeah until they did the most American
thing they joined the military
yep and then wow it's actually the most
decorated unit in the in US history it's
called a 440 second unit that's amazing
and they have the most purple hearts the
most everything it's like whatever we do
man we got to get an A+ you know what I
mean worse and did you get that did they
have is there a film or documentary
about that yeah there's a few things out
there but I think one of the reasons why
there's so much like separation or what
it looks like is because a lot of these
things
aren't taught in school yeah so no one
ever knew that yeah no one knows our
contribution to the u.s. no one you know
we're always looked upon as foreigners
and stuff like that right yeah so I have
a lot of like you know family members
that have been here for like three four
generations and Wow
especially in California man you know
Japanese and Chinese I've been coming
here since the 1800 and as in if you go
even further back Hawaii before even was
a part of us well everybody goes to
Hawaii
right but it's nice yeah but yet they
were there out there for a long as tile
and install my on my mom's side though
we have there was a lot of military
officers on the JibJab Japan end dude
that's cool man well you know what's
interesting is and how we get some of
those ideas so I think about how I get
some of those ideas growing up and not
thinking of Jaya someone that could is
Japanese there's someone that looks like
you it and in my first thought I
wouldn't know I think I probably I don't
know if I would go people do people go
Latino as well did they say a mix with
you what do they say I don't know I mean
we'll guess if they've been around I
think
Asians they can tell oh yeah I mean we
can't even tell each other apart oh
really no no no we can't do oh my god
that's amazing to make that announcement
yeah yeah that's a myth because we think
always you guys have like some insider
trading they're going on with it all
it's it's like you can't tell if they're
from Asia cuz they'll dress a certain
way and they'll speak the language
filipino is easy to guess kind of yeah i
mean if i hear what they're if i hear
the language i could tell what they're
speaking yeah yeah yeah but sometimes a
Laotian will sneak in and you be like
yeah that's true the laotians are very
sly yeah back in the day I couldn't tell
the difference between a Vietnamese and
the Chinese Wow it sounded the same to
me I could see that Vietnamese for me
would look like they have a little bit
darker skin yeah yep yep you know there
are some real light-skinned Vietnamese -
because you Lee mixed with Chinese see
men it's all it's all crazy dude there's
like Robert yeah there's a lot of that
going on dude that's wild man well yeah
yeah well so we didn't have so we just
didn't have anybody that was like that
yeah we didn't have so of course and
also on television you didn't see any
characters like that yeah
they haven't that little magic on that
boat little [ __ ] John Daniel whatever
that guy's name was well we're always
like some foreigner yeah or some
exchange student yeah like a liquor
store owner or something but you know I
mean I don't really I can't say I blame
the media because if you think about the
brave Asians right the ones that move in
to the rest of America they are the
foreigners right they're the ones like
that set up a nail salon in the middle
of the Midwest or something right
because it's oversaturated out here in
LA and you know communities out here
that's been here for about a hundred
years plus they kind of stick to their
own like they don't they're not out
there making a ton of noise yeah that's
that's the difference so I think we're
kind of like the quiet Americans like
I've been around for a long time but
people aren't sure what to make of us
you know right yeah now I kind of limey
nigh think yeah I mean I wish that I was
I wish that where I was from was like
more of a quiet Americans I think a lot
of it is I think sometimes the media
just does a lot of things than news and
says that these places are being allowed
these places like this and they're
really not you know it's like I think
it's really interesting it when you say
that you know so now do you get upset if
you guys like to say you guys you know
there's a group of someone from Japan or
an Asian person that goes into a smaller
town the Midwest and opens up like you
said businesses that are pretty like in
New Orleans has a lot of Vietnamese
fishing people here in that industry
there's a lot of um people in the
service industry right like I have some
friends are wedding planners they're
like but but do you get upset if there's
a sitcom or a joke where they've joke
about an Asian nail shop you guys don't
get upset though do you well I mean
there are people that might i personally
don't i don't know here i mean cuz i
don't think that they represent who I am
but there's a lot of people out there
that do I say and these are the I think
majority of them is because like they
might be the only Asian kid in their
neighborhood right and then their
friends see that and think that that's
who they are
I say but I mean you're in LA and then
you have access to a lot of us right so
you know that there's a huge range
yeah but that's almost as if like let's
say someone let's say you were the only
white guy in Japan right right and let's
say somebody from Russia comes and does
something and then they look at you and
then you're like oh we're not the same
right I'm gonna merican white guy and
that's that's a Russian guy yeah
that's the same thing oh I see so
there's no wow that's interesting yeah
yeah so it's a totally different you
know from north to south I mean Asia is
a huge huge plot of land yeah and part
of it is you're right data's don't teach
us enough about it yeah I mean the first
time that I heard about the four 442nd
did you say it was four yeah yeah it's
just you right now you know telling me
oh wow and so it's like you know it just
gives me a little bit of a different
idea now when I think about the military
yeah because all I ever thought was you
know when I was a kid is GI Joe you know
you see on there you know and he's white
he was white and you know everybody in
there was but they had a little bit of
diversity but it was you know you don't
even know what colors they were used
yeah very vague it was like mostly why
guys in like a purple guy that supposed
to be everybody else yeah that's like a
light kind of a mall of or something and
I think that's women going back to
Hollywood or just mainstream media and
all that stuff I think they had a
chokehold on the information for so damn
long yes that we we never were able to
have this conversation like a like a
Japanese do from California and a white
guy from Louisiana you know like they
controlled how our images work yeah and
I grew up thinking white people from the
south were automatically just raise this
and ignorant and all that stuff until I
started traveling and meeting people and
I'm like man you guys are like the
nicest people on earth man way nicer
than calop California people you know
like and it changes my perspective and I
think that's what the internet is doing
now is like it's making this possible
right and and I think I like I like
what's going on now because it's like
all these possibilities where our
grandparents never had the chance to do
everybody had to do it through the news
or through the mainstream media the only
way the only way man or in a small
little community setting but I mean
traveling miles apart and meaning
together becoming friends having fans
that are like you know did you ever
think you would have Asian fans
California right ever and then I have
fans that are just like 50 year old
Midwest moms and stuff yeah and I'm just
this is crazy but this is cool because
we're figuring out that we're more alike
than different yeah yeah dude as you're
saying some of the stuff man yeah I'm
thinking back to like a sudden you're
talking with a it felt like being a kid
and like yeah like I mean I grew up in
an environment where we probably were
like if you don't listen to some of our
conversations and stuff like we were
probably probably like oh these kids are
[ __ ] racist you know yeah but a lot of
stuff was just things we just didn't
know yeah you know and like and when you
also when you're like certain levels of
class levels socio-economic the only
thing you can different everybody's so
[ __ ] Portland thing even like you just
point out people's easiest things to see
you know and we never had any influence
yeah of course we never had any
influence that's out of black and white
so like but hearing that when I was on
y'all show and you guys had Joe come up
the [ __ ] that I used to joke about and
feel okay joking about like dude these
these people were more like me than I am
like me which was just crazy changed
yeah because the you you you're afraid
to say afraid right but I mean that it
makes sense though and it goes both ways
like I have this theory right that
whoever's in control of your area
controls your mind so what that what I
mean by that is like growing up in LA
having a lot of people in that are
controlling the education that are super
left-wing liberals the type of stuff
that we grow up learning is why people
are the enemy
right that's and then I grew up with
maybe like five white kids and all of my
schools up right until I went to college
and you you know in in a lot of
minorities Minds you automatically just
think why people are gonna be racist
they're not gonna include you and it's
it's kind of like a bad place to start
and I don't think that's the truth but
that's the type of education that were
kind of drilled to believe and it
already sets us up in a way where
there's separation it doesn't come from
a place of like oh we're all American
right and I'm sure to like hearing
from all of my friends that grew up in
red states like just like what you said
you didn't grow up hearing about all the
contributions that minorities did so
then you think hey rowdy kid and if we
like oh you karate you just karate
stance I can see why there's so many you
know white guys coming out thinking like
man we're doing all this stuff and we
got to give out handouts we're working
so hard and you guys get to do it make
sense you know I get it because I'm
right in the middle and I see it all
happening and I'm like oh [ __ ]
we're fighting for scraps right like
what's really going on yeah you know and
I think it's just the programming and
one of the one of the things that made
me go holy [ __ ] this is really happening
is when I was in Texas
my my girlfriend's a family reunion I
was just scrolling around looking at the
news it's all red like red state
conservative stuff go to Arizona
same thing on my phone I'm like this is
crazy I never clicked this stuff when I
get back in California all liberal news
yeah so I'm like man people weren't
given a choice to look at two different
things and come together and none of
that stuff it's yeah you're taught one
thing and if you don't believe that then
you're a traitor yeah that's [ __ ] up
man
yeah it's you know what I was just
talking nickel a while ago about yeah
like something is this mist that's been
missing and I feel like it's been
missing too even in my own life and
childhood growing up in everything is
some of the so a lot of conversations
have never been had
mm-hmm I don't feel like yeah yeah you
know it's like a lot of conversation
have never been had it's like you know I
need to hear that you know that yeah
there's like there's you know that
Hollywood is like yeah that's a certain
neighborhood in Los Angeles but there's
still a huge predominate of of people
here yeah like I have a lot of Latino
fans that come out to my shows and stuff
yeah and I'll have some middle-eastern
fans that come out too and I'm like what
that's not true I have a [ __ ] these
guys out of their minds you know yeah
but so a lot of that stuff's just like
yeah it makes me think like wow like
[Music]
yeah if we can how do we find how do we
realize that we're not
our programming you know yeah I mean
that's the hard part
because that comes with knowing yourself
self-control I mean like I always say
comics sometimes make the best
philosophers because they went through a
lot of [ __ ]
right but most people um I think I think
you kind of don't understand that you
have control over your thoughts control
over your actions control over what you
read they're just reacting to life yeah
you know I was impulsive as [ __ ]
so I know personally like I just did
drugs whenever I wanted to
Wow and I didn't think about the next
step like you know what I mean like and
I think that's how most people live
their lives so they don't know you know
that a lot of this [ __ ] can be dealt
with if they just took better care of
themselves
yeah thought before they acted yeah yeah
we've become very responsive ya know
yeah I'm very impulsive cuz it's almost
one of the only feelings that we have
left sometimes is reaction because we're
not interacting I think as much yeah and
when you're not interacting you're just
you don't you know you're not getting
the full picture you're just getting
this little bitty bullet you're not
seeing the whole weapon you know yeah I
think a lot of [ __ ] started changing for
me when I started traveling yeah seeing
people face-to-face meeting people
instead of like letting what I was
taught about you know certain people or
boogieman or whatever yeah then you just
start being afraid of everything you
know and if someone represents that kind
of thought then you attack them like hey
you're one of those people you're you're
racist or you're whatever you don't even
have a conversation and I'm like damn
that's crazy cuz I was like that yeah it
is so funny man I was like that too
you know I mean growing up like even
though I had a black friends I was in a
group called NFL you know which was
inward for life you know damn I know I
was in the only [ __ ] like it I
definitely should not have been allowed
in the group oh it was a it was like a
it was a game like it was a black Club
there's a black Club I mean tight
basically people were like are you guys
that you guys have guns I'm like we
don't have dads we have bikes so but I
was like a crew it was like yeah yeah
yeah like a but I was like but then I
had a lot of anger sometimes towards
black kids because you know I got jumped
by
by black kids a couple times yeah and it
just made me and someone have been my
friends and I didn't understand it at
all yeah and at that point like we also
kind of went our separate ways we're
like most of the black kids in my town
didn't go to school after eighth grade
they just disappeared you know they just
they didn't go to school at all you know
they were all they were welcome and
allowed just like anybody else there
were our classmates but they just
disappeared yeah you know they went off
and got in a caught up in other stuff
yeah yeah yeah so yeah I mean I had a
lot of but I have to you know I realize
now like I don't have anger towards like
individual black people you know but I
do have they're probably remnant to that
you know yeah where it does make me
angry sometimes but that doesn't mean
that towards a general population that I
feel that way no no I think the older I
become I start treating it as a
case-by-case yeah you know like I think
it's hard to do that when you're kid
though no I mean I you know I I even got
into it with a neo-nazi gang and
Huntington Beach like on the beach got
into a rumble for no reason and but then
does that change my view on why people
as a whole know like but back then I
hate it I was just like well [ __ ]
they're all races you all want to fight
me yeah but I mean that's like a street
gang you know you can't you can't grow
up thinking well I got robbed by a [ __ ]
so I hate all blacks like it doesn't
they don't represent the general public
of that group you know it doesn't make
it doesn't make sense but when you're a
kid all you see is that bad dude did me
wrong so all of them are must they must
be like and some of that's a safety
precaution as a child I think as a child
if you hit by lightning yeah dude the
next time you see a [ __ ] right feel a
raindrop on your cheek you're gonna be
like [ __ ] the sky you know I bet you
there's some kind of evolutionary truth
to that [ __ ] that's kind of like if a
snake bites you then you you're afraid
of snakes right yeah well you're not
yeah you're afraid of at least that the
amphibian area of the zoo so if an Asian
dude like steals your shoes then you
always wash your shoes around Asians or
something right and it would be silly
for you not to write for you as a Cho
young person right it would be silly for
you not to yeah like it would be AB
natural I think for you not to mm-hmm
instinctually but as vendors we age if
we're able to if you have the blessing
enough to live long enough yeah then you
can start to see things in a little bit
different it's kind of like that you
know about that stupid-ass hipster
couple that went to Isis territory and
they yeah they ended up getting killed
Jack does the they're on the other end
of like niceness you know I mean ya know
everyone's cool and [ __ ] everybody ain't
cool no man and a lot of places aren't
cool like and America is like going
through a time we're also like diversity
is like only really been like happening
heavily into a lot of different cities
like since colleges started you know
really bringing in a lot of different
cultures yeah like a lot more students
are moving in from different countries
and going to like universities you know
like international students and like so
you're starting to see like a lot more
cultures pop up in America mm-hmm
especially like in the last 20 30 years
where they're becoming prolific and
getting voices like you guys have a JK
news like like you guys have a huge
audience four million up 5 million
people and it's like and you have a
voice you know and it's and the crazy
thing is that I realize the voice isn't
that's different mm-hmm yeah that's I
mean that's what it's all about right I
think it's all about us being a real
democracy like America being able to
come together and share voices of like
what we really mean like our like us
like real people from the community
talking about how they feel and what
they think not our representatives or
not what the media says agreed so cuz I
mean you know like you're you're in
Hollywood you know how much they control
the script you know how much the worst
that's why we're here that's why you and
I are doing our own things yes and
people I think they're tired of that
[ __ ] that's why they're listen to people
like us because that's what they want to
hear they don't wanna hear that [ __ ]
when you turn on the news and then you
know you know it's it's fake as hell and
it's so sensationalized and they always
focus on negative negative [ __ ] yeah to
get people all riled up so they could
click that and click this and I think
what's happening now is they're so
desperate that they got a they got a
look for [ __ ] that makes people go oh my
god another guy died I got to clear this
I got a click
yeah yeah it's yeah it's definitely
gotten that way but the blessing in that
I think long-term is that a lot of that
news has jumped the shark you know it's
like oh people are like oh this isn't it
costs if it costs half a million dollars
to make that show today
you're like a lot of people getting paid
along those lines and have an influence
and have an input whereas you know you
know things can be more grassroots at
our level
ya know where it's like yeah you don't
make him you know nearly the money you
make off of advertising on a big show
but also you have the blessing of like
being able to try and have a moment to
be genuine yeah and at least you know
and recognize people are I mean yeah man
I mean I even feel bad about probably
some of the things I said I've said
about into Asian people growing up you
know sitting here when with you it makes
me think about that a little bit you
know what's cool is that
humans grow like we changed yeah even
every cell in our body every 10 years
it's a whole different person
yeah and and the type of people we are
we should never stick with us forever
yeah like like I've done some stupid
[ __ ] in the past that I mean I would
never do today yeah and but that's what
kind of sucks is like nowadays like it
people will dig up some [ __ ] that you
said five years ago and him and then
kind of you know make that haunt you I
[ __ ] hate that I hate that too yeah
cuz it sucks it's like you got to give
people a chance to change you got to you
got to give people a chance to say I
don't think like that anymore this is
what I believe now and I learned my
lesson because how else are we gonna
grow yeah that's a thing how do we
expect the America to change exactly
we're not even willing to let individual
change yep like you're gonna hold
somebody else accountable for something
10 years ago it's kind of some of the
same group think it's like or some of
the same to think that goes on in
America like I can't do anything about
somebody white that was here [ __ ] 200
years ago yeah nothing I can do about it
yeah you know I mean my father's from
Nicaragua my mother grew up in Chicago
you know like the first stop on the
Underground Railroad like the only place
to get off the train you know like my
family wasn't involved in all that kind
of [ __ ] you know the racist stuff but
it's like yeah you have to let people
change you have to it's so true man and
I and I have to remember it you know
yeah and then it's all it's all about
not taking anything personally because
it might be
that you're just a representation of
what they you don't mean like maybe some
some white dude nothing wrong to
somebody or like and then they look at
you like oh this dude yeah you know or
or you just don't know like that's what
I that's what I came to realize it was
like man it's not about me it's their
image it's their reality I'm just a I'm
just the character in their show yeah
and it's like maybe they got swindled by
an Asian dude and then they're like I
can't just another Asian ever again yeah
you never mean so yeah the Chinese
finger trap they've lived in all ten
fingers yeah steal your wallet that'll
trick you like oh yeah I remember I got
pulled up in art college town one time
and have five fingers you put them in
they got trapped and then they stole
your wallet oh that's crazy
pretty awesome though yeah I mean but
but all I could do is be the balance
right you know and I loved that man be
the balance yeah cuz if they meet you
and they realize oh [ __ ] you know what I
was wrong
yeah you know instead of perpetuating
whatever they thought you could kind of
like freaking Jedi mind-trick them yeah
and then be like no I'm cool man this is
cool yeah it's like you get a chance
every time you meet somebody to show
them a different example yeah and I and
I kind of think that this is something
that minorities or specifically in my
culture we knew that it was a it was a
group thing like any time any other
group encounters a Japanese person we're
representing we have the the the whole
race we have that responsibility on our
shoulders uh speak and look stupid we
can't treat people wrong because they
might think all of us are that way right
but I don't think I think this is a new
concept for other people because the you
know we're a collective society so we
you know we think about the group all
the time before ourselves Wow versus and
America it's all about the individual
individual thought freedom and stuff
like that so it's like yo man that's
that's that's that other white guy
that's not me
right like and I'm not even the same
person right but there's got to be some
type of connection that everyone's got
to be responsible for mm-hmm
because if it's not
you they're gonna think that about
another guy right might be your brother
or your neighbor
yeah something else yeah yeah and it's
like how do we find out what that is you
know that's tough but I think yeah it's
like you know we just keep trying to
figure out I don't know we just stay
open to change I guess yeah for sure
and be the balance man yeah cuz I think
it's kind of I mean I'm personally like
looking at individual situations right
and it's kind of like well we have poor
white kids in America that grew up in
shady-ass situations but they don't get
government funding when it comes to
colleges they have to go through even
more [ __ ] and they're called privileged
right when they're not and then you have
you know maybe a guy like me that kind
of [ __ ] around and I get a second
chance because I'm a minority right and
my first time going to college I just
wanted the aid so I could buy weed right
so I could buy a boundary and sell that
[ __ ] so I'm taking advantage of the
system when another guy could that
really worked hard at school could have
went through it yeah I mean fortunately
it worked out well for me because I
ended up sticking with college and I
graduated but individually there's all
these different cases where people are
getting [ __ ] and they shouldn't be
because they did their job but then I
can see where you know people feel like
man that's [ __ ] up
yeah it's like we're living like we're
all we're all we're living like the the
life that two generations ago you know
I'm saying it's like you're living based
on a previous generation all the time
yep
so it's like yeah it's just I don't know
and and that's it's hard to keep it's
hard to put good boundaries and good
practices onto something or realistic
boundaries and practices that are
effective onto something that changes
constantly and America's just changing
constant yeah yeah that's true and you
can't bring back old [ __ ] like this
happened 50 years ago you're gonna do it
again but I think it's just the whole
resentment people holding on people in
the hold resentments that's yeah as a
group we got to realize the biggest
thing you can do is say let's move
onward yup that's the past you know
because when I look at it in the
positive way man we have so much talent
like we could get the best of the best
of
every group you got the you got the
Asians doing math you got ya you know
you got you got like you got like
Swedish people playing uh building
furniture like whatever that you've got
the Louisiana people making like catfish
yeah like I don't know sandwiches but
yeah yeah we got then we got the best of
the best and that's what we needed like
put up and yes yeah we can say look I'm
forced over yeah this is [ __ ] America
bro and I think a lot of people's don't
want to have American pride though yeah
I am yeah and I love it you know and and
it's so weird that it that's not a cool
thing anymore I know the cool thing is
to hate America and I'm like why yeah
I'm the kind of guy that wants to clean
up my house not just move away when it
gets dirty you know that I do it yeah I
mean my father moved here yeah and gave
us a chance you know it's like he came
from Nicaragua yeah oh and I only say
Nicaragua wants certain groups of people
because it's a risky word to say right
now
no I'm saying someday Brody I get I roll
up the windows oh [ __ ] cuz I don't want
nobody here in it yeah you might slip it
up dude all it takes is just a little
bit of dry air and your throat that's
crazy how your your half Nicaraguan but
then you still kind of identify with
white yeah yeah yeah this is where I
grew up and my dad was so old that he
couldn't teach us a lot of like Spanish
and stuff like that you know he taught
us some stuff and he took he took me one
time in Central America but but man oh
look do it as fast and I appreciate you
coming in tell us real quick so we can
finish on this note like what kind of
entrepreneurial stuff did you get into
like now so right now I have a I have a
drink shop out in Westwood and Rowland
Heights called sip this matcha green-tea
it's really delicious go check that out
mm-hmm I have a few booths over at this
food event called Smorgasburg every
Sunday it's a shrimp daddy it's it's
yeah garlic butter shrimp you know what
I gotta take you should we should take
what we should do don't go over there
strip up oh yeah [ __ ] loves shrimp
dude you guys like shrimp oh yeah man do
would eat Japanese what some do Japanese
people go to Bennet
[Laughter]
I mean the whole nation I don't know man
like no people I don't know 30 I like
you guys get in bed early bro you think
I'm that discipline nowadays yeah I do
some early nowadays I do but back in the
day though I used to sleep at like 6
a.m.
really yeah go raving all night ah yeah
how many people go to raise huh yeah the
whole country bro what kind of game do
y'all play at the house if you have a
board game um like was it like this we
grew up playing it was it just monopoly
and stuff like that oh yeah yeah yeah we
would play
yeah Monopoly just regular board games
yeah I don't I don't remember any
Japanese specific games yeah it would
just be video games oh yeah stuff Konami
remember that company Konami yes milord
yeah yeah what about Chinese checkers
yeah what about that Oh with the marbles
yeah was that the Chinese checkers right
yeah yeah I played that I played that
yep that's awesome played chess played
dominoes played everything yeah yeah and
do you guys like do Japanese people have
sex and stuff huh lots of it really
whole lot yeah can't even imagine that
because I don't watch that kind of [ __ ]
yo man well I don't like Japanese porn
but don't why oh man it's not Sandro is
it weird I mean it's just a whole
different world I mean you got it you
just gotta be in it like it's kind of
weird being in both worlds because it's
like the opposite of the u.s. yeah
everything it's just nuts
but um yeah they embrace sex it's it's
not a taboo like it's it's okay but it's
not like it's like breathing like
everybody has to [ __ ] right I mean it's
it's it's it's accepted to the point
where they have nurses there that'll
help beat off dudes that can't beat off
any more like old guys mentally disabled
or whatever like they they make their
rounds every month and they're like this
is a human meat I'm gonna beat your ass
down that's beauty and the guys are like
happy and they're like yeah yeah I was
like oh I'm gonna go rake the yard now
yeah this know that I'm putting these
binoculars down wow that's crazy dude
they should have if they had that
service in America
I can imagine right it's kind of prudish
here yeah Marika's pretty prudish ah
even though we think we're not it's
crazy because like we are cool with
violence but we are not cool with the TT
yeah and that's the weirdest thing to me
do you think sex would be more fun if
you were white person or if you were a
different ethnicity do you ever think
about that
nah I don't know it yeah I don't know I
never really yeah I never thought of
that at all I think it'd be more
efficient if I were sipping ease having
sex why I think I should get it done
quicker do for a time and [ __ ] you
pictured Japanese people to be always on
time like I definitely care for the
[ __ ] you know what's funny is that
stereotypes are not far from the truth
like if you go there the the way that
public transportation runs it's on the
DA Reilly train I don't know how they do
it well I think it cuz to me Japanese
people seem respectful of time yeah the
point we're like okay that's what I'm
supposed to be there then that's when I
will be there oh yeah yeah it's more of
a they haven't seemed have more of an
honor system and most things that they
do man I should get my ass beat if I
didn't respect time yeah yeah like like
more than greats yeah yeah my mom would
be like so I remember one time I got in
trouble for graffiti so I we had a court
date and then she was like [ __ ] I can't
find this court this is before GPS and
[ __ ] and and so what she did was she
drove to look for the court the day
before Wow
so she in timed herself how long it
would take her to get to to my hearing
so she could take me the next day and be
on time my son will be on time I was
like damn dude that's crazy but that's
how she always did [ __ ] like oh if you
have a job interview you don't know how
long it's gonna take you just go there
the day before and kind of scope out the
spot that's a lot of Honor and I'm like
wow there's a lot of respect for the
court system yeah dude man I would be
Japanese next time would you be white
yeah I think it depends maybe like I
just say yeah yeah man like God maybe
Louisiana why is Louisiana white oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
cuz a crawfish farmer is something that
I want to out man yes we should do a
sketch or something must get satellite
kind of shows like three Larry
yeah do some funny stuff buddy you know
I want to try catching catfish with my
hand really do that easy well now you're
talking about Japanese porn again that's
a thing they do down there right by now
they catch the catfish they do some
things man oh yeah they do but I think
also you also again a referencing
Japanese porn the way you keep moving it
on like that do we have a couple of yeah
it's called noodling down there noodling
did we have a couple of calls of camera
for Joe yeah we got a couple all right
all right this might be a familiar voice
hey this question is for Joe Ryan Davis
from the tinfoil hat podcast I didn't
get to ask you this when you're on our
show and you wanted them superstitious
type of Koreans
okay first of all Joe isn't Korean good
right Chinese joking good all right
that's the lion here Ryan right yeah
it's lying here right man well homeboy
looks like a straight Vikings oh yeah
doesn't he oh he could [ __ ] the snow
undeniably do you think that uh what do
you think my superstition yeah or does
that start to fade away um you know what
I think
I grew up Christian mm-hmm so my family
is not as a stereotypical Japanese
family where I think a lot of Japanese
people are a little bit they dabble a
little bit into the as you can say
darker earth yeah yeah another item but
it's an atheist country so they're more
logical than anything because they
believe in science but they do do a
little bit of the home religion machine
toe ism but it's kind of like how
Catholicism might be for most people
where they just kind of do the ritual
stuff right they're not like devout
devout but it's a part of the culture
what about reincarnation is that a
popular belief and yeah I think so cuz
Buddhism yeah yeah but for the most part
though I think they kind of um they're
more modernized now yeah yeah I didn't
grow up with too much superstition
around me I mean we would hear stuff but
everything else was the devil you know
because we're so Christian yeah
it was like Satan yeah yet you don't
play with the dark arts
oh dude armor when somebody came in with
a bag a big league chew dude and I
[ __ ] put similar to my mouth I
couldn't even [ __ ] breathe yeah
and one of the neighbors had to come
over and help get it out of my mouth and
I was like that's [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I say
you almost died yeah I choked on a big
Jew did I'm a minor leaguer bro when it
comes to [ __ ] face snacks can we get
one more question to answer I love big
true by the way this was good oh yeah we
had a couple we had uh we had um when I
got older we had a couple of alcoholics
I think there were Chinese or just had
really tan yeah and uh actually it could
have been a Mexican guy that had been in
a fire even but um so he's always squint
is just real skin that kind of bronzed
and thin but that they would stand me
big league chew by the bus stop all day
and the bus stop was broken down no bus
ever went there so you just use it as a
bench just to chill on I think they were
waiting for the but they were literally
there probably six years oh my god let's
check one more Sapna Theo Jo what's up
you over like a load of weapons I carry
around with you I was just wondering
besides the guns what is your favorite
weapon oh wow peace out well that
doesn't make a fan because he knows all
this stuff that I have oh that's cool
you have a lot of weapons and that's Sam
neighbor sent that question and thank
you Sam he's from another country I'm
not sure where it sounds a bit more
dreamlike yet seem like British or maybe
one of those small villages he's on
break from Hogwarts uh yeah what your
favorite weapon oh man i i'd say i just
recently got this walking stick okay so
it looks like an old man's cane but it's
got all these spikes and ridges and
stuff and so when i walk around the
neighborhood at night i just use that
cuz it looks pretty chill hmm but what's
in it no it's just it's just a cane but
it's solid as hell and you can hook
people with hit you couldn't like kind
of smack them around and it just looks
like a geezers cane you
but before that I used to walk around
with a big staff like I'm freaking
Merlin Wow
and then the cops wouldn't even bat an
eye because it was like ah just some
this amazing guy with a cane guy little
tokyo with the came and i just fit the
stereotype yeah
just fit in the stereotype is a big
walking stick I mean it's huge it looks
like a wizard staff yeah some I'm
walking around there and and if some
crack kid wants to get too close I just
yeah yeah you'll serve him some crack
yeah we're just living out stereotypes
Joe Jitsu Kawa thank you so much for
being here today
yo man Thank You Theo I love be like man
this is I was really looking forward to
being on the show and I'm late it's
pretty awesome always talking to you man
yeah same same here man I really
appreciate it dude it's been neat too
yeah like your buddy Bart who works with
you on JK news is texting with him the
other day yeah he has been neat man like
because my circle of friends and my life
has been like it's been diverse in the
white world and in some other
ethnicities especially when I was
younger growing up but you know mostly
like you said here in Los Angeles even
though like outside of like comedy and
doing comedy like most of my friends are
kind of a little bit similar yeah
similar to me yeah yeah but it's nice to
it's neat to feel like that there's
commonalities and that could change you
know yeah man
a hundred percent so we'll have to talk
about stuff more stuff in the future
yeah for sure we'll get some burgers in
and and new shrimps and rice and when I
mix it all up just get more shrimp so
bad
Joe jet Sakawa thank you so much peace
[Music]
like these leaves I must be I'll share
this piece of thought it's gonna take
little town for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one